hello everyone and welcome back to the
champions showdown uh it's round three
and it's magnus carlson versus fabiano
corona two old rivals as the two of them
played a uh world chase championship
match in 2020
but this is just 960 and here anything
can happen
uh and it's a pretty pretty
uh wild position it's not like in the
game carlson versus as far off here you
already have the queens facing bishops
and
you know it's uh pretty crazy the kings
are in the center of the board and the
rooks are
on the cnf file uh but again only after
a few moves the
position will resemble uh normal chess
now before we check out the actual game
uh i have two very short announcements
uh
well uh first one from the youtube
channel lignum i made a chess board for
me it's a
a custom made chessboard and there's an
entire video about how he
crafts it you know how he works with the
wood so if you guys are interested in
that
do check it out it will be the first
link in the description below
and second announcement again motorino
is added again he's on a quest
to say uh sorry about that 101 000 times
so if you guys are interested in that
check it out it will be the second link
in the in the description below
now let's continue with the game magnus
with the white pieces opens with
knight to f3 so sort of a chess 960 r80
going on
we have g6 uh makes sense you want to
open up this
bishop's diagonal and the g3 magnus will
do the same we have c5
striking in the center and d3 with
knight to c6 going after that d4 squared
this is the idea
behind the fab is opening and bishop to
c3 now magnus wants to trade off this
very strong bishop
and if fabi trades magnus immediately
gets his knight into the game so fabi of
course declines this with knight to f6
and now magnus cleared everything needed
for castling
and here he just casts so for those of
you who are only joining us and don't
know how castling works in chess 960
you just move your king uh to the right
or to the left two squares like you
would in regular chess
and after you do that the pieces end up
in the exact same spot as they would if
you were playing regular chess
so that's uh you know all there is about
it
we have d6 by fabi continuing
development preparing to bring the
bishop into the game and
knight b to d2 with ideas of maybe
striking in the center with e4
bishop d7 from fabi and b3 now now both
the bishop and
the queen are acting on this diagonal so
the knight has to be very careful
uh we have e5 closing up the the
diagonal and
uh well now knight to c4 by playing e5
fobby really weakened the d6 spawn so
magnus immediately goes after it at
night the
c4 goes after the d6 pawn fabi defends
it queen to b8 and now
uh of course uh magnus doesn't want to
allow b5 from fabi so he plays a4 he
doesn't want his knife to be kicked away
from the c4 square
uh we have uh castles by fabi he also
cleared uh everything needed for
castling here so castles
uh and e3 uh just nicely uh
setting up a solid position and here
fabi goes bishop to h3 puts pressure on
the rook here
rook to e1 and now h6 taking away the g5
square from carlson's pieces
also at some point at night the h7
followed by f5
will will be an idea uh we have knight
f to d2 uh preparing to shift the knight
uh
uh over over to over to the center we
have rook c to d8 and
now rook to b1 again maybe with ideas of
playing b4 at some point queen to c7 by
fabi
uh and now uh e for by magnus if you go
for something like uh
like this it's it's very dangerous for
example captures captures captures and
captures and while you do
uh open up some lines here maybe you
could even double up rook rooks here
like e4 is coming once uh fabio opens up
this diagonal
he's the one with the bishop player he
still has a dark square bishop you don't
and
it could be very tricky so instead after
this
queen to c7 move magnus plays e4 and now
he controls the d5 square but he gives
gives up control of the d4 square so
fab immediately grabs this outpost for
his knight knight to d4
and now magnus wants to improve the
position of this knight as it's one of
his pieces that's not
doing all that much so he shifts this
knight to e3
this knight cannot come to d5 and uh he
freed up the c4 square for this knight
so just
uh improving the uh the position of your
pieces with bishop back to e6 grabbing
control of this
d5 square and now knight d to c4
just improving the position of his
pieces and now finally
knight to h7 fabi is now ready to strike
with well obviously not that but with f5
and if magnus trades is going to be very
good for him and also he can just
continue pushing with
f4 so magnus decides to remove one of
the defenders of the f5 square
bishop captures on d4 we have e c
captures on d4 attacking the knight
knight to d5 attacking the queen and
here we have captures captures and now
there are no more defenders of the f5
square so fabi's free to push so
f5 and fabi's uh doing very well here
magnus needs to decide how to activate
the queen and how to do something with
his rooks his uh
knight is an excellent piece his bishop
is also very nice
so here c3 opening up the c file and
this will definitely activate
the white queen so here fabi trades uh d
captures on c3 we have queen captures
and now queen to f7 although you could
make a discovery here with e4 it doesn't
really do all that much queen d2 goes
after the h6 s6 pawn which is undefended
and uh i mean what you're going to do
grab on d3
you only help magnus it's his pawns that
are doubled so
uh you don't really you don't really
gain anything by doing this and maybe
you want to save it maybe you want to go
f4 uh later on so here queen to f7
fabi and now even prepares f4 and now
queen
back to d2 going after this h6 pawn
uh f4 by fabi defending while attacking
and now
bishop to e4 not allowing f3 to close up
his lightweight bishop so bishop to e4
and
knight the g5 now fabi's pieces are
coming closer and closer to carlson's
king
we have queen to e2 grabbing more
control of the
of the f3 square and also if the queen
somehow
gets uh gets to the h3 square you want
to be able to play queen to f1 to
prevent any checkmating ideas
uh and here fabi does exactly that he
goes queen to d7
uh prepares to launch the queen to h3
but also gives up the g6 pawn
and here again it's a rapid game not a
lot of time on the clock uh going for
bishop captures and g6 would be
would be maybe too greedy even though it
is playable for example bishop captures
and after captures captures you run into
knight f3 check
or fabio would win the exchange but you
would have compensation because you've
well
opened up the black king however magnus
first goes king to h1
this fixes all of his issues as he
doesn't have to worry about any checks
but he gives uh fabi the move so look to
f6
uh favi now defends the g6 pawn and he
still uh retains
all the threats uh rook the g1 by magnus
now
with ideas of maybe opening up the g
file as the five is king still occupies
the g
file but now rook d to f8 now
piling up on the f file now captures
this possible just pushing the pawn is
possible magnus has to take
a lot of it into consideration and while
you could
try and open up the g file by capturing
on f4
uh for example after rook captures and
bishop captures here you allow rook
captures and f2
and now you cannot allow queen h3 so
you'd have to go queen to h5 and now
it's a
well it's a very very tricky position
for example black could go rook to f3
with ideas of rook h3 followed by rook
captures which would end the game
uh but luckily magnus would have rook to
b2 and now you have to trade rooks
because if you persist
then white gives up the queen and white
will be better here for example
you just capture the rook and after rook
captures on h5 you're gonna capture here
and it's uh well white has uh sufficient
uh control not sufficient
black doesn't really have any moves here
for example a bishop g7
rook g4 you close up all of the files
and diagonals and
it's it would be very hard for black to
even try and find a move here
like this knight doesn't have anywhere
to go it's uh pretty pretty crazy stuff
the bishop completely locked in the
queen unable to to join the party
so white would be better here now well
that is
something to consider magnus decides to
go for g4 instead
uh but this allows fabi uh well just uh
just uh a beautiful uh opportunity to
win the exchange which he goes for
knight to h3
uh puts pressure on the rook and now
magnus doesn't wanna
uh doesn't wanna react to this rook uh
so rather he just plays f3 he gives up
the exchange
but in doing so uh something uh
something beautiful happens
here fabic takes the exchange knight
captures on g1
rook captures uh and here if you look at
it it's very very difficult for
uh for fabi to even uh find use for his
rooks now
with with his pawn structure being as it
is uh the rooks are pretty much
uh useless here the bishop not really
doing all that much and it's
it's a question what the queen will do
here so here fabi goes g5 he wants to
probably open up the position with h5
but magnus beats him to the punch he
goes
h4 uh fabi captures on h4
and now queen to f2 goes after this pawn
but
also after the a7 pawn and the a7 pawn
is even more important
because queen g7 by fabi and now queen
captures on a7
and now with the a7 pawn removed black
will no longer have the option of
something like a6 b5 and with this pawn
structure
as it is the knight cemented on c4 uh
the rooks will never be able to enter
the game the bishop will not be able to
enter the game and the queen will not be
able to enter the game
so all of this white got by sacrificing
the exchange
and uh it it's just uh amazing black is
black is without a move here so fabi
goes queen is seven
uh king the h2 by magnus just improving
the position of the king
uh we have rook uh to f7 uh sorry rook
six to f7
and now queen to b6 getting the queen
out of the way going after the d6 pawn
now
rook to d8 defending and now rook to c1
magnus wants to get rid of this knight
he will shift the knight over to d2 move
the bishop
plays the knights to e4 and he wants to
bring this rook to c7
at some point if it will be possible so
bishop to f6
by uh by fabi if you try h5 black will
i mean white will just ignore you he can
either capture or even push g5 you can
never capture because rook g1 just wins
the queen
uh and if you do anything else let's say
rook g7
you already have support from the bishop
and this is just amazing for white
so here after rook c5 rook to c1 we have
bishop to f6 fabi wants to prepare this
uh
opening of the position but now knight
d2 magnus continues with his plan of
shifting the knight over here we have
rook g7
and now bishop to f5 uh just serving as
additional support here
bishop to e6 check will be an idea in
the future
we have h5 and here magnus just captures
it we have g
captures here and now e4 he wants to
open up some
some lines uh to to go after carlson's
king but it's not easy so he does have
to give back some material
and here h6 looks very strong h6 attacks
the rook also you have support for h7
but magnus first prepares it knight
captures on e4
puts pressure on the bishop and now
bishop to b2
uh getting bishop out of the way
attacking carlson's rook but now rook c2
again attacks the bishop and bishop back
to a3 now now okay the pawn is defended
twice but now comes h6 from carlson
rook the g3 trying to give back the
exchange in order to
create some attacking chances here of
course magnus not interested in this
uh he couldn't care less about that rook
he just goes rook to c7 a very nice rook
leave the black unable to block the
bishop covers the d7 square he has to
move he plays queen to f8 but now of
course the position is completely
winning it's a mate in six with best
play from white
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding
any move in the position as any move
here wins it would be
it would be incredibly difficult to find
a movie in this position that doesn't
win the game
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's a bishop to e6 or
bishop to h7 or
queen to d4 or or just any any move uh
because it's all winning here bishop to
e6 is the quickest this is made in six
magnus chose bishop to h7 check but it's
it's the same line so it doesn't really
matter uh so here
king to h8 and queen to d4 with check
uh and it was uh in this position that
fabiano caruana resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh you could block with the queen with
the rook
but i mean that's just giving up
material for example rook blocks you
you'll deliver
this with check if queen captures then
of course queen captures his checkmate
so you'd have to capture here now you
can even grab this and bring a knight
into the game with a nice double check
and after king h6 just rook to h7
is checkmate because the knights cover
both g5
and g6 squares so
uh once again i do hope you enjoyed it
really really amazing game for magnus
and just so i don't forget here
are the standings uh the the
on the cross table from the chess 24
website uh
sorry about that that's not the cross
table uh
just give me a second there we go
all right uh so this is the cross table
from chess24 website let's just uh
check it out to see who's doing how uh
so the leaders after the first day after
the three rounds are magnus carlsen
and uh a linear dominguez uh followed by
the official
world chess 960 champion wesley so with
two points and then we have
a lot of people with one and a half
points hikaru nakamura gary kasparov
levan aaron and fabiano corona peter
svidler alireza firuja with half a point
and the maxime basher lagrav with
zero out of three so tough tournament
for maxine
uh we'll see if it improves from him for
him uh and yeah magnus uh
only lost one one draw to that caspar of
game work as part of
wiggled out with that sneaky sneaky rook
move that
you know it was really just uh just um
a beautiful bluff and it really uh you
know
threw through magnus office game uh and
then uh after having a great game in
round one and two against alireza and
magnus
kasparov lost in in uh his game three to
peter svidler
so that's what happened in day one uh
we'll see what happens in day two so
once again uh
i do hope you enjoyed these games i'm
very excited as i
well in the in the like two years ago i
didn't really enjoy chess 960 but
now i'm a huge fan of the chess 960
because i just realized it's
it's nothing but a new position already
as of move one and
what could be what could be greater than
that uh so yeah uh once again i would
like to thank uh chess with suyash
kimura and tyler humel for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the champions showdown
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend
and do check out the two links in the
description below
see you soon